we've been talking extensively about the
proposed repeal of the Affordable Care
Act known as Obamacare and the statement
of the American Health Care Act known as
at least to me as republic hair or GOP
care there has been an analysis done of
who stands to lose the most or to be
damaged the most by the plan as proposed
by Republican so far this may surprise
you this may not surprise you it didn't
surprise me the Americans who stand to
lose the most from the proposed repeal
of Obamacare and replacement with the
recently released aaha are none other
than Donald Trump voters according to a
new analysis from upshot voters who
would be eligible for a tax credit that
would be that that would so let me
restate it voters who under the new plan
would be eligible for a tax credit would
be receiving at least 1000 fewer dollars
in subsidy then they are eligible for
under Obamacare and that group supported
Donald Trump by a seven point margin
over Hillary Clinton and the voters hit
the harvest those who would be eligible
for a five-thousand-dollar tax credit
I'm sorry for the largest tax credit
might receive a five-thousand-dollar
smaller tax credit under the Republican
plan they overwhelmingly supported
Donald Trump over Hillary Clinton by a
59 to 36 margin so I know I didn't
necessarily explain it in the simplest
way we're going to put up a graph for
our audience that's watching along with
us and as you can see here looking at
the different groups and if you're just
listening to me check out the data on
this from from upshot the more you stand
to lose in terms of subsidies under the
Republican proposed bill the more likely
you are by and large to have supported
Donald Trump over Hillary Clinton this
is in part because the Republican plan
offers less assistance to older and
lower-income Americans particularly in
rural areas according to Kaiser
data and members of those groups are
more likely to have voted for Donald
Trump than for Hillary Clinton the older
and rural Americans would be hit harder
because the proposal for the aaha would
not provide a larger tax credit to
people with more expensive plans and as
you may know not only do older Americans
already pay the highest premiums the
proposed aah a republic hair would allow
insurers to raise premiums drastically
on older Americans the AARP the American
Association for retired people or
persons I don't remember exactly not
exactly known as a liberal group they
oppose this plan and as I was reading
this Pat I was struck it's almost like
many Trump voters cluelessly voted
against their own best interests were
you as shocked as I was to hear that no
I'm not surprised at all I mean if you
break the states based off of how much
they pay out in federal taxes versus how
much they pay in the makers in this
instance tend to be for more liberal
states i mean california is a prime
example and it makes sense because in
some of these southern more rural areas
they may benefit off of the social
safety net a little bit more things like
the stat program things like medicaid so
these people tend to vote for Trump and
you know they're voting against their
own interests we've known this for a
long time and now this applies to health
care as well well you you by mentioning
California this is sort of the next
point I was going to get to which is
that there's another layer to this so
already just based on the subsidies that
people would would gain or lose under
this plan Trump voters will be
disproportionately hurt by this proposal
okay but there's another issue which is
if you look at states like our home
state of Massachusetts which already had
a program that predated and exceeded
Obamacare in terms of what it provided
to residents of Massachusetts if you
look at states like California for
example other liberal states these are
states where in the absence of the
Affordable Care Act have not only the
political will and desire but also the
finances to take care of this problem
for people at us no doubt at a state
expense there's it won't be free but
they have the political will and the
finances to do it many of these
particularly red states not only don't
have an interest if the ACA goes away
and saying hey we're going to create
something new to make sure people don't
lose coverage because we've heard from
Republicans increasingly that it doesn't
matter if people lose coverage we need a
free-market moral system in their view
they don't have the money because a lot
of times it's the red states that
actually financially are depending on
both the federal government and the
excess paying into the federal
government coffers from States in order
to fund their day-to-day operations so
not only will be the specifics of the
aaha hurt more Trump voters than than
clinton voters or non-trump voters which
is the majority of americans you're also
going to see that those red states are
going to be both unable and unwilling to
actually try to resolve the problem that
will be caused by the repeal of the
Affordable Care Act we might hear this
as progressives and say David aha
finally Republicans are going to get
blamed no no no not so fast it would
make sense when you have a Republican
president Republican control of the
House and Senate and mostly Republican
governors that is health care goes south
you blame Republicans but I would not
jump to that conclusion yet because the
Republicans will say something like if
it wasn't for how badly Obamacare
destroyed everything it never would have
been so bad in the first place or
they'll come up with something else
Trump already suggested last week hey
republic hair doesn't pass let's just
let Obamacare fail maybe because we
don't fund it properly and then we'll
just blame Democrats and then they can
probably ride that into re-election
campaigns so maybe the trumpets won't
care if their health care prices explode
as long as you can keep Muslims and
Mexicans out maybe they'll hold
Democrats to blame I don't know but I
wouldn't assume that it will just be
victory for Democrats in that case
today's program made possible in part by
blue apron for under ten bucks a meal
blue ape
we'll deliver easy-to-follow seasonal
recipes with you know I like it
pre-portioned ingredients right to your
door no more overspending at restaurants
or ending up with ingredients that you
end up putting in the trash because you
bought too much of it not to mention
blue apron has also partnered with 150
local farms fisheries and ranchers all
over the US and you get the exact amount
of each ingredient required no food
waste some of the Veals available in
March include salmon piccata with orzo
and broccoli vegetable chili and baked
sweet potatoes with crispy tortilla
strips and I actually made this one last
week excellent spicy shrimp coconut
curry with cabbage and rice you can
check out this week's menu get your
first 3 meals for free you also get free
shipping by going to blue apron calm /
Pakman that's blue apron calm / PA ke ma
n you will love not only how good it
feels but also tastes to create great
home-cooked meals with blue aprons check
it out three meals for free blue apron
calm / PA ke ma n